>> Sean: DONALD TRUMP JR. WENT
ON THE VIEW TODAY TO PROMOTE HIS
BRAND-NEW BOOK WHICH ALSO
HAPPENS TO DESCRIBE THE SCENE
SURROUNDING HIS APPEARANCE WITH
THE LADIES OF THE VIEW.
>> LOWERING THE DISCOURSE TO HIS
LEVEL, EVEN IF PEOPLE ARE
WORKING, WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE A
COUNTRY LIKE THAT.
>> WE'VE ALL DONE THINGS THAT WE
REGRET, IF WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
BRINGING THE DISCOURSE DOWN.
YOU HAVE WORN BLACK FACE.
ROMAN POLANSKI, IT WASN'T RAPE
RAPE WHEN HE RAPED A CHILD.
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW,
DONALD TRUMP JR.
YOU'VE GOT TO TELL SAYS HELLO.
>> HANNITY SAYS HELLO, GUYS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: I'M WATCHING THIS
THING TODAY AND I'M LIKE WHY?
WHY DID YOU EVEN BOTHER?
WHY?
>> EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE YOU
HAVE TO TRY, SPEAK TO EVERYONE,
IN THAT CASE THEY DIDN'T BECAUSE
HE WOULD THINK IF YOU'RE INVITED
ON THE SHOW AND THEY GIVE YOU
THREE SEGMENTS, YOU WOULD THINK
IF YOU ARE THERE TO PROMOTE A
BOOK, THEY WOULD ASK YOU ONE
QUESTION ABOUT THE ACTUAL BOOK
BUT THEY DIDN'T DO THAT.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHY I
WROTE IT, THE TITLE SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF, I DON'T THINK THEY LIKE
ME MUCH ANYMORE.
>> Sean: I USED TO DO ALL
THOSE STUPID SHOWS, THE LAST
TIME I WENT ON THAT SHOW, ROSIE
O'DONNELL WAS HOSTING AND LOST
HER MIND AND POOR
BARBARA WALTERS COULDN'T CONTROL
THE CHAOS.
THE REALITY IS LOOK AT THIS
WHOLE MEDIA THING -- OKAY,
THERE'S A QUID PRO QUO, THERE'S
NO QUID PRO QUO.
YOUR FATHER HAS FAITHFULLY
EXECUTED THE LAWS BUT THERE WAS
A QUID PRO QUO AND THAT IS JOE
WHO KNEW HIS SON WAS BEING
INVESTIGATED, YOU FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR, YOU GET A BILLION,
YOU DON'T FIRE THE PROSECUTOR,
YOU DON'T GET A BILLION.
QUID PRO QUO JOE, DON.
>> IT'S ON TAPE IN FRONT OF
EVERYONE AND HE'S SAYING IT THAT
WAY, THERE'S NO AMBIGUITY, NO
NOTHING.
HE WAS IN CONTROL OF IT, HUNTER
BIDEN IS GETTING BOARDS OF
COMPANIES AND LANGUAGES HE CAN'T
SPEAK, WHY ARE YOU THERE?
I'M NEVER REALLY THOUGHT ABOUT
THAT -- WELL I KNOW WHY YOU'RE
THERE.
I THINK EVERYONE IN AMERICA
KNOWS WHY YOU ARE THERE.
WE ARE HAVING A GOOD TIME IN
BIRMINGHAM, ALABAMA, DOING A
LITTLE BIT OF A TRIGGERED TOUR
BUT I THINK THESE GUYS ARE ALL
IN AGREEMENT WITH US.
>> Sean: 90 MILES NORTH OF
BIRMINGHAM, I WAS BROADCASTING
IN HUNTSVILLE, ALABAMA, A GREAT
TWO YEARS THERE AND THE
NEWSPAPER, WROTE AN EDITORIAL
WHEN I LEFT, GOODBYE TO THE TALK
SHOW HOST FROM HELL -- I WAS
VERY PROUD OF THAT.
I WILL SAY THIS.
>> THAT SOUNDS LIKE MY AVERAGE
DAY.
>> Sean: I THINK WE ARE IN THE
SAME BOAT.
IF A KID WEARING A MAGA HAT, THE
LIES, THE SLANDER, THE SMEARS, I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY -- I
THINK THE NEXT 362 DAYS IS GOING
TO BE A WAR EVERY DAY TO DESTROY
YOU, YOUR FAMILY, YOUR DAD WITH
LIES BECAUSE I HAD BEEN LYING
NOW FOR THREE YEARS.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT COME YOU
SAW WHAT HAPPENED TO ME
YESTERDAY, I LITERALLY RETWEETED
THE ARTICLE WITH THE NAME OF THE
SUPPOSE IT WHISTLE-BLOWER IN THE
TITLE OF THE ARTICLE AND THERE
IS OUTRAGE.
IT WAS ON DRUDGE FOUR DAYS AGO,
IT'S ON REAL CLEAR POLITICS, IT
WAS IN BREITBART, A COUPLE OTHER
PLACES.
HE'S IN DANGER OF HIS LIFE --
THIS IS A CIA OPERATIVE IN
DANGER OF HIS LIFE?
I WISH THEY WOULD'VE SHOWN A
LITTLE BIT OF THE SAME AMOUNT OF
OUTRAGE WHEN MY FAMILY OPENED UP
A WHITE POWDER SUBSTANCE IN AN
EXPLODING ENVELOPE THAT SHOWED
UP AT MY HOUSE.
THESE GUYS ARE FULL OF IT.
THEY AREN'T OUTRAGE THAT HE WAS
OUTED, THERE OUTRAGE THAT NOW IN
HIS NAME IS OUT THERE, EVERYONE
IS ABLE TO REALIZE THIS IS A GUY
THAT'S TIED TO BRENNAN, THIS IS
A GUY THAT'S TIED TO SUSAN RICE,
THIS IS A GUY WHO WORKED FOR
BIDEN WITH THE UKRAINE NONSENSE
AND THIS IS A GUY WHOSE LAWYER
HAS BEEN TWEETING SINCE JANUARY
OF 2017, THE COUP HAS STARTED,
IMPEACHMENT IS NEXT, WE ARE
GOING TO GET TRUMP OUT OF THERE.
THIS IS A JOKE AND THEY REALIZE
THEY GOT CAUGHT IN THE ACT AGAIN
BECAUSE THEY WANTED THIS
INNOCENT PUBLIC SERVANT
WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO IS DOING THE
RIGHT THING INSTEAD OF JUST
ANOTHER ONE OF THE COUP CABAL OF
THOSE CLOWNS WHO HAVE BEEN DOING
THIS FOR THREE YEARS.
THE REALITY IS THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC GETS IT, THEY SEE THROUGH
THIS NONSENSE, THEY ARE SICK OF
IT AS I AM AND THEY SHOULD BE.
IF IT'S GOING ON HERE IN AMERICA
AND 2019, WE SHOULD ALL BE
ASHAMED OF OURSELVES THAT THEY
ARE TRYING TO OVERTHROW A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T GET THE RESULTS THEY
WANTED AND THEY WANT TO PROMOTE
THEIR SOCIALIST LEFTIST POLICIES
AND THAT'S THE ONLY THING THAT
MATTERS, THAT'S DISGUSTING.
BUT THIS WAS GOING ON IN A
BANANA REPUBLIC, WE WOULD BE
OUTRAGED, IT'S GOING ON HERE IN
AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: DON, JR., WE WISH YOU
THE BEST.
SEND MY LOVE TO ALL OF MY
FRIENDS IN BIRMINGHAM -- THEY